the good trouble event was held in honor
of former georgia congressman john lewis
a year after his death
madison kimbra was at the gathering
today and heard from several community
leaders
she joins us live in the newsroom with
the latest details madison
yeah sasha right now the spotlight is
shining on voting rights
as the nation marks one year since the
death of civil rights icon john lewis so
today
i spoke to activists who say they are
working to keep his message
alive community leaders from all around
gathered to honor john lewis on the
first year anniversary of his death
they continue to work to get his message
out and say there's still so much work
to be done
today we're gathering together to make a
statement
a long overdue statement a statement
that we need to have
equal rights for everyone especially
here
in this state but we want to be free now
lewis spent almost his entire life as an
advocate for equal voting rights
and now activists are using his message
to push congress to pass federal
legislation
that would protect voting access for all
it's also about making sure that
every voice is heard at the ballot box
why are there groups
who are working so hard to
disenfranchise voters
it's because they know when you vote
there's power in 1965
lewis was beaten by police as he marched
for voting rights across the edmond
pettis bridge in selma alabama
still he kept fighting and ultimately
the voting rights act of 1965 was passed
prohibiting racial discrimination in
voting since days of selma
you know he worked hard for making sure
that every american had a chance to
exercise the right
and at the same time nowadays we're
carrying on his legacy for those bills
that are on the you know waiting on the
senate to act
towards the end of the speeches a
candlelight vigil was held in lewis's
honor
and the message was clear fighting for
equal voting rights for all
is a daily commitment it's not just
during election season this act but like
days like today like
days to act they still remember like hey
this is a
365-day process of staying active with
our communities
now other than hartsford congresswoman
dina titus was also in attendance
along with state assemblywoman chandra
summers armstrong
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now